[Music]
federal law prohibits filming of
endangered falcons
except for educational purposes to avoid
federal crimes
and maximum penalty of up to five years
in prison the following comedy sketch
has been edited in post-production
to be educational viewer discretion is
advised
oh real pretty bird you're pretty cool
oh
oh shh it's okay you're pretty burnt
here what the hell are you doing this is
our
falcon crowder crowdershop.com mascot
i'm going to teach you
how to hunt and you can you don't really
think about falconing
[Music]
actually it's falconry which
historically was a popular sport and
status symbol among
the nobles of medieval europe and japan
where it's called
takaguri falconry has been around
forever
and may have even been started in
mesopotamia
[Music]
he's got a look he's got a hysterical
little helmet with the
spear good question steven
the falcons hood used during the phase
of its acclimating to humans
which is referred to as the manning
process is used to keep the
raptor in a calm state both in early
parts of its training
and throughout its life
[Music]
you think we could get it to attack
[Music]
brandon
do you want to attack brendan yes
falcons aren't naturally human
aggressive orchestra will do well
starting with
chicken hearts livers then switching to
other meats like
sparrows other small birds ducks
ducks and pigeons and then move on to
mice and
insects so remember if you see a falcon
in the wild
it's more afraid of you than you are of
him
to her
falcons may be badass but not as badass
as merchandise
which you can get at crowdershop.com
[Music]
what's
[Music]
changes
that was that was a tame slurp and uh
the reason for that is because today
i'm going to be my best behavior you do
because dave landau hey can someone
bring where's dave landau he's doing a
show tonight let's uh plug that there
later but he couldn't be here today oh
so papa crowder is here how are you uh
public rider fantastic you make that
desk look minuscule from this angle well
that's because i'm jacked as hell
[Laughter]
you guys want to put on some muscle man
no it's just called cracking your femur
and getting fat uh gerald a is here
quarter black gareth is here how are you
good morn that's not
black at all um i'm a falconer we have a
lot falconry we have a lot to get today
we have jason whitlock on the show oh no
who actually is sports yeah sports he uh
he's gotten into hot water he's out he's
a he was a division one uh
uh athlete athlete division one athlete
uh hosted shows at espn fox sports
and was recently suspended from twitter
black guy who's spoken out against black
lives matter why
sorry a person of color uh speaking out
against uh
persons of colors lives matter black
lives matter needs to change the may
you know what you and the united negro's
college fund
get your act together yeah i haven't
changed it
uh so we're going to talk about that
we're going to be talking about trevor
noah who uh has still maintained his
[ __ ] haircut
during quarantine uh as virtue signaling
which is a good shape up man yeah and he
supports uh
purity blockers for kids um we're gonna
be talking about court packing we have a
lot to get to
um and uh uh pop squad you don't have to
keep looking at yourself like oprah you
know
he always gets in and he's super quiet
you can't have you ever been able to get
him to shut up outside
no you know have a conversation i'm
going to end up on media matters you
will anyway
well it's going to happen with one
comment well
you can do it we don't care you're a
senior so you get special rights you can
steal stuff what
i'm confused i'm confused where was the
oval office
right this way where's my vaccine
um here's something before i get to
anything else look there there are so
many conspiracies that go around
with this show and sometimes you realize
they're just they're based in some truth
they're based in no truth at all there's
no
conspiracy going around that betty is
dead
you can't kill that dog because we
haven't now here's the thing betty has
been gone
she went to special training you know to
become a support dog for my wife yeah
and there have been some complications
right so my question today is actually
going to be very personal and i really
could use
your advice genuinely i'm conflicted
about this and i know it's weird to
start it with my dog but here's the
thing betty was gone for several months
to be
trained right she goes to this farm in
kentucky yeah and she
loves it there she runs around with the
dogs and she loves chasing animals like
she's just an insane dog
she came back and so we were doing this
for instance getting this video ready
like betty's gonna come back you know
like you know when soldiers come home
right not exactly the reaction that i
was expecting here you go here's betty
after not seeing me for three months the
grand
oh reveal gosh i don't care
ran right to joe lewis betty come here
and then ran past me again
my question to you is like look i hate
it when people say like oh i just love
my dog but then i moved to an apartment
that doesn't take dogs so
you know i don't have a dog anymore so
no that's your family yeah um i've never
had a dog
for anything other than the entirety of
its life however
betty has fallen in love with this great
dane over there at this farm in kentucky
she loves it there's no way that i can
make her as happy at my house
joe lewis would not do well on a farm he
wants me with his people betty just
wants to be
running like let her out all day run
around with a pack of dogs like a
gang of marauders yeah and come back in
woody i want to do what's best for her
but i want to be a good
what would you do genuinely would you
say okay betty go and
live on this farm not we're not putting
her down actually live on a farm
a real farm okay so what is more
selfish of me it's it's tough because
joe louis likes her but she
let her go i've thought about it but i
just you know i i yeah well maybe free
betty
all right uh okay so but we have a a lot
of other stuff to get to but uh this is
a clip that's been going viral
and i just love it for all the right
reasons
and all the wrong reasons dan vongino
and uh geraldo rivera remember him
yeah he still has a show takes his
shirtless selfies in the gym glorious
mustache he's a fan of those shirtless
selfies
we're not here's dan bongino and geraldo
rivera getting into it
uh with geraldo rivera calling dan a son
of a [ __ ] on air on fox news
where is some of this massive things
this man
this man is why they have that rage data
he doesn't know anything about
that woman this is a he doesn't
you tell that to the families that see
oh they're trying to play them off
that's
you just want to see the country burn
that's it i want to see the country burn
you son
you wouldn't tell me that to my face
we'll leave it there
by the way we'll leave it there is 98
hey don't return my calls anymore what
we just talked there's no issue we just
spoke like three days ago dan what are
you talking about
son of a [ __ ] no you're a son of a
[ __ ] you punk i don't know why he does
this no
i gave you the recipe for the the the
the spicy meatballs myself privately
yeah and then you released it on
instagram dan
he just hung up he hung out oh okay yeah
son of a [ __ ] i'm easy to find
let's move on to the next story here i
am i'm going into bat for him yeah i
know
calls red i mean can't believe it little
sicilian more
[Laughter]
i saw true romance uh okay so he's hard
to peg dan though
i think he's sicilian at least
no i think that's uh anyway so here's
another thing and this is another story
here
by the way that what are they doing now
hey is that the judge not wearing his
turtle shell mask
look at this look at this did they lift
the mask mandate in the courtroom
will not testify he will invoke his
fifth amendment rights
we also heard that the prosecution will
call rebuttal witnesses and the judge
mentioned newly discovered evidence
uh that's notable but first laura to
your
reaction to chauvin's decision there not
to testify
okay let's go back that's exactly why i
hate cable news no
added value hey this is what you're
watching
let's talk about what you're watching
let's invade what it is that interests
you with our uninteresting conversation
i'm so glad i don't have to do that crap
anymore so here's another example cnn
right they send their reporters out on
the ground yeah to the the black lives
matter riots it escalated pretty quickly
in
brooklyn center and of course they fired
the brooklyn center uh manager
uh because he said that we need to wait
for due process right for the police i
mean how dare he
how dare he do that say that i mean we
wouldn't want due process for the black
cop
involved with this no um so
uh after the shooting of dante wright
right there was this
obviously the riots and then cnn sent
down a crew they were physically
assaulted
pretty brutally and then chased off um
[Music]
all good i'm an ally
and here they are trying to leave get to
their car they're being followed
which by the way happened with me at the
uh union protest in lansing only the guy
showed me his gun
yeah it's all piece when a guy is
leaving and you're following him to the
car
and still committing assault and battery
now watch this watch watch this
[Music]
you hit the car there's a it's a novelty
license plate it says
tits bit now
can you believe that i can't believe
that we're supposed to negotiate with
these people
like they aren't children looking for an
excuse for violence you know what you
deserve
when you throw a water bottle at an old
man you deserve to get your ass kicked
that would be justice no justice no
peace
all right i guess you want to go old
irish fighting style that would be
justice
yeah no no i want to throw water bottles
from from oh no don't grab that that's
my ghp bottle we got a kid that's
that's a high ticket item now here's the
here's the issue too
did cnn this these were cnn reporters
yeah did cnn cover it at all
token allen you're supposed to be on the
overlays here
for cnn did they cover did they cover it
it was miguel the guy who was attacking
miguel marquez overlay a overlay b this
is the guy who was attacked
oh his dogs are in the car and then did
cnn cover it no
that's overlay b token
okay his respiration yeah this is his
response too so cnn didn't cover any of
it
uh at all i thought we were supposed to
have a number i went through cnn all
morning
nothing there so you can go there right
now cnn.com they send out their
reporters
their reporters get violently attacked
and they
do nothing to protect them so it's
cowards
sending out seemingly cowards those
reporters as well oh it's all good i'm
an ally
in order to cover cowards and say that
it's all peaceful and then it's all
about strength and this is something
we've talked about you know i've had
people
take swings at me when we've gone out
and done changed my mind we've had the
uh the beautiful brave transgender
males who you know through a homeless
man's lunchbox that's right
that's um try to steal my sign but like
especially we've had women out there
you guys have always known i said like
hey protect protect them make sure that
they're safe
yeah i have to make sure that i control
myself that i don't go ape
[ __ ] livid crazy if someone hurts a
member of my crew
yeah at the very least you'd see some
righteous anger
no one there does anything hey when you
talk about solidarity
no one at cnn is going to walk for
putting your reporters in harm's way
hey this is the message by the way
anyone out there because cnn no one
actually watches them they make a lot of
their money from on-the-ground footage
right that they sort of license
you if if you want to be safe don't work
for cnn
they'll let anything happen to you and
they won't protect you and as a matter
of fact they'll cover for the people who
attack you they'll call them peaceful
protesters
yeah exactly as long as it fits their
narrative they're fine with it i don't
know by the way
halfway through that you see the guy run
up ready to jump into something he's
like what are we doing what are we doing
where's the fight it's like this is the
mentality of the people that are out
there right now this is not about
getting justice it's not about making
sure that your voices are heard this is
about looking for a fight this is about
being in high school
and seeing something happening running
over and trying to get involved well no
they're not they're not looking for a
fight gerald
these are people that have never been
accountable to anybody right and they're
not looking for a fight at all they want
to
chirp from the bushes yeah these aren't
people and had it had it been the other
way where it was a trump rally or some
kind of conservative function
seeing them would have covered it yeah
they would have been all over if one
person got hit in head with a water
bottle
and by the way what does a water bottle
weigh a couple of pounds also you don't
know what they're filling it with
exactly but even if it's just water
you're like oh you got no are you
serious
he wasn't looking he was an old man and
he threw it from behind and then the
guys come in saying they're looking for
a fight
it's almost like the water bottles are
the arrows you know they take down some
of the numbers
and then the other guy okay now we can
come in and now we're the immortals
no you're [ __ ] that's all of you okay
just to be really clear
and cnn they're cowards they're absolute
cowards i can't believe they didn't go
into bat for their own guys
so they say we're peaceful then cnn says
oh we're with you
yeah they show their bias yeah and even
the guy this is what i was reading yeah
the guy
the guy uh responded marquez who was hit
by the way
my team and i are fine and i appreciate
your concern i hope for equal justice
under the law and will continue to
report on this vital story as it unfolds
that's like when dick cheney shot a guy
in the face and he made him apologize
which i think i am in the extreme
minority here in that i really don't
like a lot of dick cheney's policy
but i adore him as a person and no one
else feels that way
just because i when he when he leaned
into john edwards microphone if you guys
don't remember this people out there i
know we have a lot of younger viewers
just so you know language warning he was
debating john edwards remember this and
john edwards brought up his daughter
being a lesbian like you should support
this with your daughter
and after the debate they finished it
and dick cheney leaned in and said
deliberately by the way because he sent
it into john edwards lapel mike he said
you can go [ __ ] yourself for that look
at me you can go [ __ ] yourself for that
it wasn't it wasn't an accidental like
hot mic he knew exactly what he was
doing
so probably safer to work for him than
cnn hey uh i'm on instagram by the way
lyder with crowder if you guys want to
follow me the best thing you can do for
this show is just tune in too live
monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern
uh we're going to be taking your mug
club chat and uh along with jason
whitlock a little bit later
um so my question to you is what you
think about court packing
and then how long do you think until
there are no more women's records in
sports we're going to get to trevor noah
in a little bit genuinely you can just
the best thing is just comment comment
come that helps with the youtube
algorithms and
it's always a pretty nice community
there compared to most youtube comments
well it sounds like a loaded question
but it's not it's not a question no no
don't you know
it's not reality anymore you're
anti-science if you think that men
uh are biologically superior to women in
athletic endeavors
right just want to make sure
we're all on the same delusional page
here yes i don't want to be a big still
have weight classes in men's sports so
yeah no and we also not for long we also
have anti-doping policies in men's
sports
all right we'll save it for the trevor
segment because i want him to see it and
i want to
i want to concentrate it like a little
like a little hate
concept like hate from concentrate um
so biden and the democrats right now
this is what people are talking about
packing the court and what does that
mean
it doesn't just mean like you know
putting them on a smaller bench it means
that they want to
add seats to the court now here's what's
interesting about this
um biden's point of view has changed
dramatically
over the years kind of i mean like
hillary clinton with gay marriage or
barack obama with
gay marriage or kamala harris with gay
marriage and weed
um yeah so for people who don't know
let's set the stage because now
democrats are actually
pushing forward it was supposed to be an
investigation into whether they should
pack the court
democrats said let's stop with the
leader let's just do it
but here's biden then and now i remember
this soul adage about
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely
corrupted by power in my view unveiled
his court packing plan
you wanted to increase the number of
justices to 15
allowing himself to nominate those
additional judges
it took an act of courage in the part of
his own party
institutionally to stand up against this
power grab don't know my opinion that's
reasonable the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
other than other than focusing on what's
happening now
if they vote out before the election you
are open to expanding the court
i'm open to considering what happens
from that point on listen i know he's
spent
59 sorry 64 years in public office
but he goes against the grain in that he
delivers direct answers this man is no
one's
manchurian puppet i'm not i'm not saying
that i won't
not do it you trying to wiggle out of
this i forgot the question
i have no idea where i am next question
please i love how he doesn't contradict
himself at least
yeah no exactly this is look this guy's
not this guy's not running the show
right now former vice president joe
biden um
really before we move on to the court
packing i think uh we actually have to
check in uh some falcon facts with uh
on the ground with thomas finnegan
thomas are you there sir hi steven
thank you for having me yeah a couple of
quick falcon facts for you
good
[Music]
we'll check back in with him um because
google's usually something google's
usually pretty nice yeah
the falcon by the way it's because we
couldn't we wrote a bunch of falcon
sketches and then we were told it was
illegal
but you needed to have them on solely
for educational purposes
and um we spent we spent a lot of money
making this happen so
it actually attacked him with the hood
on garrett oh yeah i don't know
i have no idea maybe something about
thomas that's kind of
a so with the packing the supreme court
uh
biden established a commission like i
was saying to study
reforming the supreme court last week
that he announces right
yeah the commission will produce quote
an analysis of the principal arguments
of the contemporary public debate for
and against
supreme court reform you know with
including the appraisal
of the merits and legality and pretty
okay so they're like okay they're
proposing
now uh house democrats and jerry nadler
they're just going to be introducing
legislation today
right to add four four justices to the
supreme court
they just didn't even think about one
this one right past it like ah four is
the magic number here
wonder why what happened to the blue
ribbon panel what does that mean a blue
ribbon panel
i have no idea i'm insulted at all now
here's the thing we've talked about this
in the change my mind with the acb
confirming acb
uh people say well why why why don't we
just we've added justices to the courts
in the past
well over a hundred years ago okay the
last time why do we have nine justices
let's be clear for people who don't
understand it i'll explain to you a
little bit of the history
and then we'll get to why this is a
horrible idea uh the last one was in
1869
1869 this was during reconstruction
where we added
the justice and we decided on nine and
that's because think about it you're in
a point reconstruction you're talking
about after the civil war
it was more of a pragmatic reason
because you'd have these justices these
judges who would have to travel all
around to these circuit courts and so
they divided them into certain
basically considered regional sort of
responsibilities
and they needed that amount of judges
that's why they changed it
they haven't changed it since uh i think
it was actually fdr wanted to do it and
even democrats were
vehemently opposed to it so um this is
something that may surprise a lot of
people but
not that it's determined by polls not
that policy needs to be determined by
pulse but the vast majority of americans
i should say the majority of americans
also oppose
port pak well it was 53 rasmussen yeah
yeah well it was a practical decision
too when they did it to nine they said
look the court is about three years
behind on cases right now we need
circuit courts
in the south especially to make sure we
just fought a civil war these guys still
have
the same values and same principles that
we were fighting against we need circuit
court judges down there so we're going
to have the circuit court judges
and now we need to get through this
backlog of cases so nine is the number
it was actually reduced to seven in 1866
basically to prevent the president
from being able to nominate any justices
at all right and so it was kind of put
back so there was a practical
reason for removing it please name the
practical reason right now
oh me nobody can that's the thing there
is no reason to move the number oh i
thought you said the proper resonance
before i'm like you just
listed it that was weird that was weird
phraseology there gerald you're usually
better at this i think your eyes glazed
over for a second maybe that's what it
was
yeah no there is no particular reason no
there's none whatsoever not at all
i thought it was a trick question like
right now now i was like what is there
i don't think there is one now anybody
i don't know was there a conversation i
thought we all agreed it was [ __ ]
right is it
is that the trick trick question is the
answer d [ __ ]
it's still d okay always d and by the
way this isn't uh this isn't new even
ruth bader ginsburg
was against court packing we have the
quote right here well if anything it
would make the court appear partisan
it would be that one side saying well
we're in power it was only to enlarge
the number of judges so we'll have to
have more people who will vote the way
we want them to so i'm not at all
in favor of that solution to what i see
as a temporary situation
um here's the thing it's very dangerous
you guys can just go back to schoolhouse
rock three branches of government yeah
trick question jill what are the three
branches oh no
uh he got it wrong the answer is
you do you have judicial rights
legislative executive
right and then a bill comes out and goes
i'm transgender
oh yeah where did cnn fit in that
z yeah well they're getting pelted with
they're just getting pelted with
concrete water bottles
um judicial is supposed to be the least
politicized yeah it's supposed to be
separate and apart right it really is
supposed to be
a non-political branch of government
however we know that's not necessarily
the case right we know that judges
can be partisan but that's not what
they're supposed to be there used to be
a debate in this country at one point
about judicial activism you know sort of
about how people approach if they were
originalists right if they were uh
contextualists with the constitution
but it still was designed to at least
keep up the appearance
the air of impartiality they've blown
way past that right now and they were
accusing donald trump of packing the
courts by filling vacant seats in his
final year which again there's plenty of
historical precedent for that
there is not for simply adding seats to
the court
without a pragmatic geographic reason
before
the gift of flight the humans
um mass flight mass transit before
certainly before the biden uh acela
express whatever it's called there from
new york to to baltimore and you know
what look this is just here's here's the
issue if you haven't thought about this
right now if they add four core of four
judges to the court okay it's now
whatever democrats want
right and then it just becomes an arms
race republican let's add three
let's add four let's add five once you
start this
you cannot put that genie back in the
bottle it
is a fundamental change of how our
government works
and are you okay with it the next time
a trump is in power if you're a leftist
because i'll tell you what
my views have changed a little bit where
i think all of us really well
listen principled conservatism and those
things still matter but now also yeah
but we're tired of being trampled on
when
it's like boxing and someone keeps
kicking you in the nuts at a certain
point when you keep kneeing me in the
pills
all right uh if the refs not calling it
we're gonna need you back and i'll tell
you this
if this is i'm someone who's always
opposed court packing if you add four
seats
we should add five it's done the rule
the gloves are off
yeah never want it to be that way but
then it just becomes about winning
and irritating you placing sand in all
the right places
that becomes my raison diet yeah well
the supreme court was supposed to be the
the court of last resort essentially
right so if we have a disagreement as a
country on an issue either individual
whatever it is
you take it to them finally it's been
through every single process
you need that to be that court to go by
our founding documents and say no here's
what this actually says
you don't need it to be political and so
that the the connection right now is
merrick garland versus acb
you guys wouldn't let us have merrick
garland in the last year of obama you
ended up pushing through acb in the last
year of trump
i understand you don't like how the
system works but that doesn't mean you
change the rules and break the system
this
is what every single leftist policy is
right now
we don't like the system so let's get
rid of it okay well what would you
replace it with we have no idea
yeah or something okay well what would
you do
uh send in a social worker when a guy
has a gun pointed at somebody yeah
that's gonna work out really well send
in a send in a social worker who has a
an undergrad uh degree in uh in spanish
studies yeah
someone with a schizophrenic bender
thinks the tv is talking to him
it's just makes common sense sitting in
the bathtub with a blow dryer just
waiting for you
well it's the same thing with the
filibuster too you know ford yeah yeah
it just depends on who's in power
it depends on who's in power yeah it's
like what are you gonna do why do you
need an issue with the supreme court
because now you have you have
uh you have more yeah okay so what do
you want to do we would
we we would like to have more than you
well why well because we want judges to
have our opinion yeah i thought they
were supposed to be impartial
they are hey what about title ix does it
include dicks
it does now yeah have you seen the world
record books
um by the way this is another quick
story ben and jerry's i don't know if
you saw this ben and jerry's yesterday
they uh weighed in on the dante right
shooting went full vote this is a tweet
from ben and jerry
i don't know if they manage their own
twitter they're probably too busy been
getting on jerry
doing a little bit of the uh little bit
of the uh the fish food
a little bit of the chunky monkey what
i'm talking about i don't know
i'm saying they're having sex lost ben
and jerry i think
them and their silly little clueless
looking fisherman's hats
the murder of dante wright is their
tweet the murder of hashtag dante wright
is rooted in white supremacy will they
explain the reason now we know
and results from the intentional
criminalization of black and brown
communities
this system can't be reformed it must be
dismantled
and a real system of public safety
rebuilt from the ground up
hashtag defund the police like you just
said it's just like dismantle the system
all right how about you go out there how
about you handle the beats
constable ben and jerry we'll give you a
truancy baton don't use it on each other
and just for that that's paid for by
taxpayer dollars
just for comparison how hard is it to
create content stephen versus edit
content yeah one would argue it's a
little bit different it's a little bit
different in fact
nobody in the history of the world has
created what we have here so it's been
done
one time yeah don't think that you can
tear things down and rebuild them better
it's very hard to do and it's very easy
to build them back worse
although it's pretty easy to replace you
with the blowup though honestly
sometimes people like it i
think we should kill the that's the
problem that's your problem because you
can't kill a doll gerald yes you can
it's not a living organism
it told me so ben jerry's ben and
jerry's they just gave us the reason
it's white supremacy we now know it's
white supremacy ice cream makers from
the state of vermont have told you what
the problem is
and uh of course it's got really uh it's
got a lot of uh steam
behind it on social media though some
think they were tone deaf uh
missing the mark a little bit with their
celebratory offering
jamaican me tasey and that seems like
it's a little bit
yeah it's topical off the mark you know
what you need to
fire your social media director ben and
jerry i know they're telling you to give
hot takes
you screwed up yeah at least it's a
taser on that one yeah it's lisa
it's a taser i just yeah i can't believe
that some people were mad there's like
this woman probably shouldn't have been
in the force
yeah because she why well because she
was yelling taser taser taser taser with
a gun that everyone could see
i think it's sort of as reasonable
she flagged half her partners and that
that swiped that barrel it was
terrifying that was absolutely
petrifying
accidental shooting because she didn't
know the difference between a taser and
a gun
she was trying to choose which one yeah
she's trying to choose which one
and then geraldo's like i think we
should have this on a on a strong side
then we should have a cross draw on the
other side it's like first off they're
already on separate sides
second i don't know why you are employed
by any media organization yeah
his points were so gerald's nurse wife
had a good oh yeah i was gonna i was
gonna bring that up she had a great idea
she said in medicine a lot of times and
i can't remember the full setup but like
if you have two drugs you're gonna give
and one can interact with the other and
actually cause a lot of harm to a
patient if you do it wrong medically we
know this as
a party right she said you don't keep it
at the same place like hip and hip right
you don't put them in the pockets right
and left because it's the same
mechanical movement you can go to the
wrong side
she said you put one lower on in the
other pocket that's down on the leg that
way it's a different mechanical motion
to get this
versus this right oh your hip and i
thought that was actually pretty good
it's like oh yeah because now i'm
thinking i have to lean down to get out
of this versus just right here last time
i had surgery
i was wondering about the holsters
[Laughter]
fentanyl yeah summer muscle relaxant
i'm your huckleberry an aspirin right
here no wait that was a fantasy
oh yeah that happens by the way
uh sweetheart i'll be home soon after
this the nurses outfit
make sure it's on the way um with
holsters
yes with holsters stop it yeah with hers
do you have to appendectomy find some
difficulty moving stool i've got a
suppository you are horrible at dirty
talk
that's kind of supposed to i didn't mean
literally dirty or perhaps you would
like an
oral saline solution it takes an hour
and a half to soften your stop
it
different priority yeah all right so
let's get to this you know i usually
don't address trevor noah because i
don't want to punch down
um but trevor noah now what's
interesting too this is something really
important you know trevor now all of his
videos
are uh raising they're raising money for
a non-profit if you check out youtube
right now for some covid relief thing
yeah um he uh also his videos if you
look they have these
really high view counts but very low
interaction rates comparatively so
they're always auto i don't know about
you let me know if you noticed this
always when i'm watching
content usually more conservative
content on youtube it autoplays seth
meyers or trevor noah yeah yeah
i have spoken with a lot of people a lot
of
leftist people i don't know anyone who
listens
to trevor noah or watches trevor noah i
don't know anyone who likes trevor noah
i don't know anyone who would even
give him like a save the date if he was
a relative
thrice removed with trevor noah
and he makes he's a walking straw man so
just think of it this way
how much accountability we have on this
show we have to even though it's even
though it's
a comedy show we place our sources you
know you can always click the link in
the description louderworthcrowder.com
trevor noah can just make claims and use
the most basic logical fallacies that
you will learn in your first semester at
college
and no one will ever call them on it so
this is a perfect example
and i also think look it's dangerous i
think this is dangerous and i'm not
saying someone just speak he can speak
however he wants
the issue is when trevor noah can go out
there and advocate that men
beat the hell out of women in sports and
that
children should be allowed on puberty
blockers and then the powers that be
silence and throttle opposing opinions
like
that's when you get into danger danger
is not different voices
danger is eliminating voices so that
people hear only
one and then they [ __ ] about echo
chamber yeah
so um here let's go to trevor noah a
couple of claims here that he makes
regarding
transgender athletes males in female
sports and puberty blockers and go
through it piece by piece
clip a is that when it comes to major
issues with tons of evidence
like climate change or coronavirus or
gun violence
they're like huh let's wait until we see
more evidence but now there's an issue
that barely even exists and they're like
we don't got time for evidence there's a
plastic
trophy it's like 2009 youtube now the
one thing that people making these laws
always
point to is a single story from
connecticut
a few years ago i've got 15. evidence
that trans
kids are stealing opportunities from
everyone else i think conservatives
are missing the entire point of youth
sports in the first place
because it's not really about the tiny
minority of kids who will go on to get
scholarships and perform at an elite
level it's not about that
that's exactly what sports are about
achieving their personal best developing
good habits
and self-esteem and learning to bully
the chess team no no
no sports are exactly about being the
best they're exactly about being elite
and being the best maybe some people
want some self-esteem or discipline but
the purpose for sports is to test
oneself and prove oneself and be the
best
this is now this is the issue is the
jumping off point he doesn't understand
what sports are
because maybe he's in transition i have
no idea it's tough to tell
so he doesn't understand what sports are
about he uses right away
the the very one of the very first
logical fallacies that you learn about
right you have the logical values of the
appeal to authority fallacy the
correlation does not equal causation
fallacy
and this is one that i'll use latin for
you a little bit of the romance
languages
it's called argumentum ad navitatum i
think i'm saying that correctly but
it's a fallacy and this is let me read
the textbook definition this fallacy is
the opposite of appeal to tradition
and that it is an attempt to claim that
the newness or
modernity moderninity
flanders is of something is evidence of
its truth
and superiority the novelty of the idea
or proposition does not entail
its truth or falsity so he's saying
there's no ev there's no evidence
here that look there's no problem well
look because we haven't done
it yet since the beginning of america
since world history
we haven't allowed men to dominate women
in sports
that was partially the basis for title
ix right where you wanted equal
opportunity with women's sports you
wouldn't need it if women were as good
as men
and people actually wanted to watch
women who were lower than the varsity
high school team
you wouldn't have needed title ix also
by the way let's give you an example
this would be like me suggesting today a
90
income tax rate okay we don't want this
we don't and then six months from now
people are still trying to repeal it
saying
this is this is gonna be horrible this
is devastating me going well there's no
evidence of bankruptcy yet because you
just started it
you just started allowing men into
women's sports so don't try and act like
you have a body of evidence
yeah well a couple of the things that he
listed it's a bad argument but he even
set it up poorly because he's listing
things that there is wide debate about
right if you believe in climate change
having this gigantic effect versus
having a small effect if china is going
to play a role if it's man-made
if it's a natural cause thing if it's
both like all of these things are worth
discussing and he's like these are all
terrible things that we know
exists fully right yeah he says
conservatives want to wait for more
evidence and then he tries to imply but
but the in other words he's saying oh
listen it's uh it's climate he's saying
this climate change is settled
as well as men competing in women's
sports the evidence is in
that uh there's no unfair playing field
so here's the here's the deal
we don't have a control what do you do
in any other form of science because
people have to throw this around trust
the science trust
the science like it's gaia and they have
to kneel at the altar science is an
ever evolving uh i mean really
you can you could even say art right now
certainly because there's a lot of
finessing with science
see the world health organization um but
what you have to do if you don't already
let's say with a medication or you're
looking at a supplement right
anyone out there takes supplements you
don't have the golden standard a
double-blind placebo-controlled trial
right you don't have it yet
but maybe some people are making claims
what do you do in that case
you make an inference from the science
you have available so i'm just using
this as a simple example we don't have
placebo control clinical trials what
they do is go okay
but do we have any uh controlled studies
right okay can we look at the meta
analysis can we look at sample studies
can we compare populations and then they
frame it in because there is usually
some science available it's not
conclusive now the good news here is we
have both
available science and conclusive
evidence he just lied about there's
only one example i have 15 here and they
all involve
multiple world records in in trials not
even competition
it's not even close so what science do
we have available to us considering that
we haven't done a mass experiment
with women have women having the crap
kicked out of them okay
let's look at men versus women their
hormone levels okay a man's average
testosterone level
300 to 1200 nanograms per deciliter a
woman
20 to 70. okay those numbers may not
mean but it's about 10 times the amount
testosterone what does it do this is the
science there's no doubt about this it
enhances red blood cell production
it decreases fat it increases muscle
increases bone density
connective tissue men have 24
24 to 65 percent greater bone density
than men
men have higher lung capacity than women
men have higher aerobic capacity than
women they have higher vo2 maxes
okay now let's before we get to the
direct competition that they're talking
about because they're more examples in
connecticut
let's look at the world records men's
world mecca record one mile run
three minutes 43 seconds the women's
four minutes and 12 seconds
that's an entire minute more the men's
800 freestyle swim
732 okay
women's 759 men's powerlifting squat
this is raw by the way
uh 1102 pounds okay this is raw without
gear women's
705 pounds there's a lot more at stake
here than a plastic trophy okay this is
this is something people need to
understand first off the fundamental
reason for sports is to be the best
this is the issue with social justice
wokeness this is the same root cause
of people kneeling at the football game
of people saying that you better pay the
wnba players just as much as you pay
lebron james
it's them saying well sports aren't
about who's best it's about it being
fair it's about ensuring equal outcomes
no
football is about winning the super bowl
football is about being the best team
and filling the seats
okay college sports are about winning
the national title
that's what it is and i've always said
this if you enter into the sporting
arena without the intent to be the best
you're wasting your time we're not
talking about recreational leagues
bowling i don't care you want to have
men play against women and ping-pong
fine be my guest it's hard to tell the
difference from the players there anyway
but the issue here is the it's not just
a plastic trophy
women actually get hurt because they're
not saying hey let's just keep it to
ping pong or billiards
there's once you open this how do you
say not women's contact sports
case in point fallon fox a man who lived
as a man for his entire life and
fathered children
now identifies as female shattered a
woman's orbital bone there you go
that's it holy cow
wow what a beautiful knee beautiful tie
clinton believable mother must be proud
beautiful by the way nothing i'm
watching on this screen is beautiful
so i don't know what the commentator is
beautiful beautiful what
trying to cover up nothing not even the
ring colors are beautiful
by the way fox was held as the bravest
athlete in history
oh wow it's like kramer doing karate
with children
no it's very different there are times
when you're you're competing against the
course or the clock
yeah right or the weight right you turn
it into contact sports that's another
level the first you know the first
yeah first i track and feel that kind of
thing you're denying scholarship so
you're hurting them that way
you start to get physical it's a whole
another level well you know
you know we do we never in history have
we ever had to have this conversation
before we've never had to have the
conversation are the best
men better than the best women or even
the average man and average woman you
know what they do in pee wee football
they have weight limits it doesn't
matter if you're the right age it
doesn't matter if you've played for the
team before it matters how much
you weigh if you are 10 pounds or five
pounds or one pound over that limit
you don't get to play you know why
they're protecting kids
yeah we know this it is built into every
sport that we have that has that
rule and i i hate to step on you but
you'll have liberals say well well then
why
then gender doesn't matter weight limits
okay now take the weight limit
and make a fat percentage a body fat
percentage differential of
15 because women have more body fat and
they have less bone density
okay so don't try and think that you're
cutting off at the past though i know
that trevor noah isn't thinking that far
ahead he's a walking straw man yeah he's
a walking
straw man and he's wealthier than god
and he still hasn't gotten his hair cut
because he wants to virtue signal
well what i hope happens steven is that
the liberal says that why don't you just
get rid of it
i'm happy to no women's sports no men's
sports
just sports the best compete go yeah
well you know sorry that's what you
asked for you're gonna have a few hip
fractures
so here's the thing maybe not all high
school athletes want to compete at the
elite level
but some do now trevor noah said that
this example doesn't matter but it does
and he also didn't tell you
the whole truth about this example it
happened at one time in connecticut
i now i just don't i look i don't know
if he doesn't actually look at the
research that's presented or if he's
just a compulsive liar i'm inclined to
believe the latter because
it's one paragraph in the story that he
had up there
it's in the picture don't show the
picture yet because the picture is
hysterical
so female connecticut high school
athletes they're routine not only are
they cheated out of uh
of uh athletic scholarships in
connecticut
the number one and two placing track
winners
were transgender male to females look at
that that's too transgender and the
women
aren't even close they took the top two
spots
he used one example but that has two
sub-examples
it just makes common sense trevor noah
you don't even look
at the titles of what you're presenting
okay let's go through some other
examples uh i don't know if i'm
pronouncing this right i don't care
cece tefler of franklin pierce
university won the ncaa championships
and the women's 400 meter run
of course as a biological male or as we
used to call it male
uh but uh this person claimed that their
height of
six feet was a disadvantage because it
was windy
this isn't sailing sweetheart sorry
handsome
rachel mckinnon uh here's the thing not
a biological male
i know because it's confusing you're
like rachel no that's not a name that
can go both ways
you're not wrong yeah uh won a woman's
cycling
uh world championship here's but also
set the world record
in the trial and here's what i want you
to watch in this clip
is how this rachel mckinnon this trans
athlete just rockets past this woman
without that much effort and then takes
their feet off the pedals
to coast because like i want to win but
not by that much because i'm not going
to
then they're going to make me you know
get on more hormone blockers and i don't
want to fracture my femur
so uh watch this setting the world
record and coming down the line over the
on the outside lane
takes it into world champion oh
canada yeah years of harvard paid off
for rachel mckinnon as she became the
first trans athlete to win a world
championship in track cycling
i barely managed to do it i passed her
with about 15 meters to go before the
line
and then that was it world champion
after her victory
was swift that easy fierce with people
suggesting mckinnon shouldn't have been
allowed to compete
stop cheating enter the men's
competitions reads one of the tamer
tweets
others were more hateful yes more
hateful
probably from those fathers and mothers
and people with sisters
dicks by the way i love how she says it
was only the last 15 meters um that's
called strategy in that race that's what
you're supposed to do
set the world record too in the 35 to 39
sprint yeah well
two world records now yeah right many
world records just keep keep having the
records
world champion yeah whatever hope you
enjoy your lot feminism
um here's another one hannah mouncey and
this clip is just hysterical i don't
know
trevor noah would never run this because
you know he doesn't want to he's not
he's not aiming to be funny
i never i never meant to we'll take your
word for it
agreed um hannah mounts you a biological
male a male hannah mounts a male okay
look let's just a male a male who
identifies as woman there you go
male female biological terms but now
they say you can't say biological you
have to say needle-borne male natal born
i won't
um a male who identifies as a woman okay
right is that fair
youtube because not gender sex you said
they were separate so i can use the term
hannah mounty male identifies as
woman uh was one of the australian
women's
handball team top scorers and by the way
hannah played for the men before
okay beating women in by the way
is not that much of a contact sport but
when you watch this you'll see that
hannah turns it into one yeah and see
if you could spot the difference or
maybe an advantage
uh i warn you if you have small children
who compete in athletics they probably
shouldn't watch this because they'll
quit
i'm hannah mansi pronouns are she and
her
and i thought the pronouns were third
hemsworth brother flyer business owner
dog mom
can you hear me now being treated with
the respect i deserve
come on watch it get so much worse watch
who just bit it just he just stuffed her
she just stuffed her
[Music]
[Laughter]
way again come on that's not fair it's
just this is a lie that is agreed upon
right where everyone just sits everyone
just sits and goes like uh oh yeah and
then
oh yeah hannah back there just in the
huddle uh you know just uh yeah hey come
on that's a foul but you know sometimes
gets a little handsy
and we all just we all just go along
with this giant walks into the car
you're like you must be a referee right
no no
i'm hannah what are you suggesting uh
noah right hey here's a nice here's a
lady half your size would you like to
punch her in the face
yeah it's what i do it's kind of my
thing
i punch them i punch them because
they're on an equal playing field
well hannah kind of opted for a set that
would fit into a sports bra though did
you notice he didn't go for the full
rack for the
she it is man
no he just doesn't know male who
identifies as woman i think if we're
going to play the gender rule
male who identifies as woman beats up
other females
i get a generational pass yeah i think
you do he's old grandfather
uh here's another one mary gregory again
only one example
said trevor just one he says maybe he
meant from i don't know maybe he meant
from south africa
i have no idea he doesn't know what's
going on the other side of apartheid
uh set the record mary gregory
male identifies this woman set the
masters world record for the squat
deadlift and bench press while competing
as a woman
before being stripped of the records and
then of course screaming outrage because
listen no justice no bits and pieces
new zealand that's not the only one
here's a new zealand weightlifter laurel
hubbard
uh not to be confused with the beautiful
and brave founder of scientology how are
your theater levels
good pretty good yeah pretty good so
yeah well xenos see who's proud of me
laurel hubbard won two gold medals at
the pacific games
and was by the way it was on track to
dominate the sport uh until a serious
injury uh
hubbard and this is something else
people don't talk about hubbard ruptured
ligaments in her elbow in 2018 and in
the career
hey do you know something that's really
pretty common that we know what
is that if you uh a man has low
testosterone or if you give a man
estrogen
or for example a lot of women who go
through menopause if they don't get some
kind of hormonal treatment
your bones become brittle osteoporosis
now this is something that's well known
in the community with men right we all
know that there are certain steroids men
take
that can actually benefit your muscle
protein synthesis at the cost of your
connective tissue now there are some
steroids that you can take that actually
help your connective tissue as well
but often people will talk about hey
this guy got stronger than his ligaments
could handle
and so they'll snap their ligaments it
happens all the time we know this
when we're talking about anabolic
steroid science we act as though we have
no evidence when injecting estrogen
or giving men estrogen directly however
we know this because
you have men out there who take steroids
it takes something called they take
estrogen blockers or aromatase
inhibitors and it has to be closely
monitored because if they take too much
and they end up getting their estrogen
levels out of whack one of the first
things they warn you about
is bone problems so you're now taking a
man with the bone musculature of a man
and you're giving him the hormonal
treatment of a woman to
drastically and quickly reduce bone
density
so we know it's not healthy we know it
comes with serious side effects
but for some reason we've abandoned the
science
um are worried about sesame i was going
to say rachel mckinnon i didn't know for
sure i was thinking through it she
actually was injured the cyclist
uh and so won't be competing in the
games i wonder if it had anything to do
with that i haven't looked at what
happened but
that article was talking about it as
well oh what happened i tore my scrotum
what if she experiences a numbing effect
that only a bike seat can cause every
guy understands
well yes speak for yourself that's true
uh but she also
she also had i'm sorry i looked at the
cyclists thing a little bit more because
i do cycling and thought that this would
be something representative of what i do
it's not
at all but also said well i've lost most
of my races and i'm like
really i'm sorry you lost most of your
races yeah on purpose
right if you lost most of your races you
don't know how to do sports you have
every advantage possible
and you know what actually let's put
this up at lightweightcredit.com maybe
lily or one of them can uh
um can bring it up for us um what are
you guys talking are you guys okay over
there you guys keep going back and forth
on your phone
is everything okay i'm not going back
and forth okay um here's some there's an
article i think at pink news i was just
reading this the other day someone can
find us like 10 transgender athletes
speak out
and the first ones are male to females
and they're saying what people don't
understand is that i've
undergone hormone replacement therapy
and it drastically has reduced my size
really all of the gains are gone i'm a
completely different person within uh
two or three years so people just don't
understand the science and then
down the line it shows a female to male
athlete right in ncaa i believe
basketball who's on testosterone which
is banned for male athletes
okay and then he uh she who's a female
who identifies as man
says uh well uh actually testosterone
has very little effect it might be a
little bit bigger but anyone who thinks
there's a big difference just doesn't
know the science
whoa wait which is it wait a second
which is it and here's the thing
actually females who would compete
against males who are given an exemption
where they're allowed to take
testosterone
that's also unfair because men can't
take it and it's not because
they'll get their testosterone levels to
that of a man it's that when you allow
someone an exemption remember they went
through this in the ufc
they banned it because what happened is
they said okay a lot of these fighters
they damage their endocrine system you
know they're cutting weight
their testosterone is low we'll let them
elevate it to the levels that are
uh comparable to people in their age
bracket okay this is science guys you
can go read these case studies in the
ufc
but then what happened was they realized
it was impossible to catch
people who were cheating because they
were taking water suspended testosterone
that would be in their system and out in
four hours
the term was test probe don't dope and
so it wasn't that you couldn't just get
your levels to normal it's that these
guys were
blasting it out of their minds and
because they had an exemption
they didn't have the tests to catch it
this is the guy from that pink news
article
yeah he's like testosterone doesn't make
that much of a difference after
nine people are saying i blocked my
testosterone it's amazing how small and
weak i am yeah
absolutely by the way sport being able
to participate in sports is not a human
right
no you're not guaranteed this and if you
really do think it is
fine transgender league build it yeah
go and compete against people that are
in the same situation as you are
go for it and here these are just the
very clear examples we have of men
competing in women's sports
we don't have that much yet because
again it's basically a case study but
more than one
yeah of transgender athletes but here
just when men have gone up against women
they've been historical events so
the australian women's soccer team they
lost seven to zero to a team of 15 year
old boys
and it happens regularly um this was one
thing i think it was uh venus or serene
williams who said no man out to the top
100 will be able to beat me well the
203rd ranked
german karsten brush said challenge
accepted
[Laughter]
it is me he beat both sisters back to
back
oh no and an afternoon didn't even skip
his two o'clock snack
think about it it wasn't even close can
you picture a more successful athlete
no i don't know which william's sister
is the good one i assume one is good one
is evil
no they're both good they're both good
yeah tennis at least
uh in 2017 alone men and boys okay
they beat olympian allison's felix sorry
this is the lady who set the record for
women
400 meter time of 49 seconds right they
beat
more than 15 000 times oh
what men and boys the olympian record
for women
so like 15 000 college 15 000 times it's
been beaten
so we're not saying and i hope you look
well do you think you're gonna you think
you're gonna be the william sisters at
tennis oh
no you idiot i don't play tennis okay i
don't even own tennis shoes i don't know
the difference between a sneaker in a
tennis shoe to be honest i thought
sneakers are about sneaking but it seems
like they're the same thing
the point is i'm not saying that i will
beat the tennis sisters
but a man who's ranked in the 200 the
man who wouldn't even be able to make
the show probably has to work a
part-time job flipping tires
demolish them in an afternoon i'm not
saying i would beat the world record
female sprint holder
but i'm i'm also not saying that it
requires an elite male i'm saying there
are 15
000 men who beat the female all-time
world record
and the average man kicks the [ __ ] out
of the top woman
we know this oh my gosh you know your
trans league
might be an idea gerald i would watch
that can you imagine that australian
handball
player competing against a chaz bono
that would be you know
going one way or one the other way you
know he
he she sorry
thank you yeah competing that person
whoever smashed competing in this i
would watch because
that's hilarious you need to put
transgenders in the same league with
people who are allowed to take any
steroids they want
yeah just like all right okay yeah look
exactly that's a good point
here's a needle exchange let the games
begin well
yeah unless i'd be insensitive this
would be like somebody saying i
identify as somebody who's disabled and
so i want to be able to participate
there are people who identify as
disabled
really yeah yeah i thought they're
called phantom that's the thing no it's
a real thing
don't make fun we don't want to make it
a different community hey by the way can
we bring lily in here lily
she's an intern right now and she ran
track was very high level
and she ran into this um lily if we can
bring
i didn't want to put her on the spot
lily how far are you so she to give you
a little bit of background story lily
ran track okay in high school cross
country cross country oh okay lily come
on in here and sit in the
red shirt thank you right here right the
red shirt
richard yeah there you go all right lily
thank you this is your first time on the
show yes
how is it the lights bright a little bit
bright okay lily is adorable by the way
and she's she's not available because
well listen she works long hours
and i want to keep it that way so lily
you ran cross-country right yes
okay so you ran cross-country and you
were pretty good yeah yeah
what was your ranking i was the fastest
on my team my senior year okay nice
but then you had a particular individual
who identified as female
yes so this person ran as explained rant
explain the background he she z ran
as a competitor so competed on the boys
team because it wasn't allowed
at that point but would talk about how
they were the fastest girl on the team
to me really oh yeah and how did that
make you feel
um not good okay well that's you know
what thank you lily we appreciate it
yeah okay thank you she's sweet as can
be
not good not good not good what a piece
of [ __ ] i know right
it's like like he's competing with the
boys and he's like how about i'm the
fastest girl in the school
i can't say anything no but female to
male will
always be an inferior male always and
going the other way will always be a
superior female physically
that's just the way it is yeah so i
think your league has promised said
gerald
here's another uh we've haven't cut back
to a while here's another uh
trevor noah clip and no you're not
watching youtube circa 2009 he's just
that behind the curve
so north carolina is going to make its
school
employees snitch on kids anytime that
they don't quote conform to their
gender what does that even mean
to you like like i caught up late with
the other boys in school
you're telling me that if i was in the
system today my gym teacher would be on
the phone with my mom
that's cute he's acting like he caught
up
you want to report people who don't have
coveted passports just to be clear
yeah and it's like what does that even
mean conform to your agenda
are you that stupid are you that bad at
playing stupid it's pretty clear are you
a boy or a girl we want you to come
you compete with dicks or you compete
with the chicks
dicks or chicks take your pick there is
no door number three unless you want to
be sauced out of your mind
in which case enjoy being body slammed
by brock lesnar
well he's or hannah whatever handball
player yeah same difference
um there's no such thing as conforming
to your gender well and
by the way i have to be really careful
to even talk about this on youtube
because of their policies that's why we
go to mud club afterwards so in place of
that i present to you this next video of
beautiful and brave uh caitlyn jenner
without comment
tick-tock on the clock but the party
don't stop
she's limb different you build me
up you break me down what's happening my
heart is
you got me no one knows
and the party don't start till i
walk in if you walk into a party you can
hear crickets humping
here you can hear a rat piss on cotton i
guarantee you the party stops
right away maybe a record scratcher
hurry everybody looks over everyone
is is that person wailing now the party
could start
don't stop till i turquoise puts the
lotion on its skin
now
i love how when they do that clip this
is just the lie that's agreed upon
they're all like at first
you know it's the mass saying like who's
that i don't know talk right away she's
like you know exactly that's the that's
the hit and run
yeah that's the hitting run former
medalist on the wheaties box it'll be
like turning around and they go i don't
know who is it
if six the six track on the pulling i
don't know what is it
that's the worst video why didn't the
voice change for bruce what
why is that lagging that was an upgrade
that he couldn't afford that was an
upgrade
that was an option the records caitlyn
jenner said all the mail records
no uh here's another uh trevor noah clip
as a walking star we have to get to
jason whitlock here in a couple of a
couple of minutes
uh here's another trevor noah clip
saying that it is
sexist transfo all the things he's a
walking caricature this is not just
transphobic it's also sexist and
everything else
ah because these republicans act they
act like
all they care about is the health and
well-being of the kids
yeah it kind of gives the game away when
they start adding on stuff that's
basically just
and don't play with dolls or will tell
you hold on a second you just said that
there's no such thing as conforming to
your gender
how could anything be sexist
how does that work yeah i don't
understand and not to mention
the whole premise of modern gender
theory which by the way started you go
back to simon belvoir
judith butler john money we've talked
about this we'll have all the sources
available at earthquaker.com it still
started with the idea of two genders
started with the idea that sex was
biological with some people exist on a
spectrum however
it's based on the idea that someone can
be born
with the wrong brain in the wrong body
meaning someone with a
female brain is born into a male body or
someone with a male brain born into a
female body so how can you
force that as the premise right thrusted
upon society is a lie that people agree
upon and then say by the way there are
no differences between the male and
female body
well then how could you be in the wrong
body we're all just steven spielberg
alien amoebas
none of it makes sense there's no such
thing as gender this is sexist
what is it me it's like saying there's
no such thing as ray
there's no such thing as race it's
racist
you just said it's not a thing and
here's another thing where he moves on
this is where it gets really corrosive
and look it's anti-science i want to
apologize on youtube i think that
putting
children who are not of the age of
consent on puberty blockers
permanently altering their sexual
capabilities i believe it's child abuse
okay
and i will defend that to the death if
adults want to get uh on hormone
treatment and they it doesn't affect
anybody else they don't want to compete
in women's sports there's no they can do
what they want by themselves i don't
think it should be taxpayer funded
however
zero tolerance none for children on
hormone blockers
it's not right it's not safe it's child
abuse here you go
is him uh trying to make the scientific
case keep in mind this is the man who
didn't look at the pictures or titles
of the previous articles now telling you
trust the science his science and
puberty blockers
republican lawmakers are also not
doctors and people who are doctors
see things very differently major
medical organizations such as the
american medical association and the
american academy of pediatrics
oppose the bill with alarm and dismay
pediatricians have watched bills through
state legislatures across the country it
threatens the health and well-being of
transgender youth
young people when they reach a certain
age
if they have gender dysphoria which
means that
they experience mental duress because
they are
um transgender might not want to go
through
we used to set another world record for
mental gymnastics um
puberty blockers so that they don't have
to go through puberty and can make a
decision when they're older
about whether or not they want to
medically transition me turning into a
man
is just probably the most horrifying
thing
ever i could ever think of
in the farthest reaches of my mind is me
not going on the hormone blockers
anymore it's scary for all of us
had hair where there was none before
yeah yeah puberty is not fun for anybody
to be clear you're sticky
that's most of it but his science is
there are no negative effects of puberty
blockers
well a quick rundown we'll show you
that's not true so this is from mayo
clinic weight gain hot flashes headaches
bone density problems future fertility
problems stunt to genital growth
not to mention mood disorders this is
from pubmed uh and a 42
attempted suicide rate either pre or
post-op for transgender people
look that's just that's reality and over
95
of children who think that they are born
the wrong gender grow out of it if you
don't give them purity blockers once you
give them purity blockers it drops to
zero percent
and now there's a 42 chance of attempted
suicide that's a fact to say there are
no negative effects
on children giving an eight-year-old
puberty blockers is simply
dishonest uh let's go to the i think
this is the last
trevor noah clip and trans people
themselves say that treating kids early
can be extremely beneficial
which makes you wonder what's really
behind all of these laws
if you ask me it's hate oh well that's
it
he just said it was racism it was sexism
it was transphobias and even though
gender isn't a thing
uh and now he says that it's only hate
the only reason republicans would maybe
oppose biological males competing in
women's sports or not giving puberty
blockers to six-year-olds is hate
hey you know what hey maybe it could be
love is that a thought maybe love for my
children
not wanting my uh not wanting my son or
my daughter i'm about to have twins
being a demographic that attempts
suicide forty percent of the time maybe
that i don't wanna have them to have
future health complications we're about
to have jason whitlock on the show we
know that there are a lot of people who
use performance enhancing drugs and high
levels of sports who then
ended up with cancer ended up with all
kinds of endocrine issues to say that we
don't know anything about cross-sex
hormone
replacement therapy is simply dishonest
we don't know enough about what it does
to kids yet if you entirely block
puberty
yeah but this is the thing this is what
they say oh it's only hate that's the
only reason you oppose it is hate i
don't know i would say
love health fairness and uh science that
would be my argument maybe
maybe walking with you through a very
difficult time in life and giving you an
opportunity to make an informed decision
that's why you don't want a 12-year-old
a nine-year-old a six-year-old going on
puberty blockers and by the way when you
stop
puberty what do you think at 25 they're
just going to restart it or 35 they're
just going to restart it that person
said well maybe later on they would want
to actually transition you didn't even
leave room for the idea that maybe they
would grow out of it
right because you started them on
puberty blockers already right it's done
at that point and here's the thing too
this is and
we'll bring on jason we'll check in with
thomas finnegan and mod club later but
um
here's the issue too they've also
reversed the hippocratic oath just like
earlier
trevor noah said repub republicans
conservatives they hate science because
you know there's no scientific evidence
to show that there's an advantage for
male
biological male competing women so right
now what they're saying is well look
the hippocratic oath is first do no harm
they're sin look
we'll block puberty and then if they
decide that they don't want to block
puberty well then we'll
they'll probably be fine if they
continue no no no first do no harm
we know that allowing them to go through
puberty doesn't do harm aside from the
stickiness and the gross thoughts right
it's disgusting
we all know that don't have a velour
couch around them that's tempting no
the point here is why would you put them
on puberty blockers and act as though
the least invasive methodology as a
doctor
is to put them on mind-altering puberty
blockers
and then afterwards they'll probably be
fine if they said they don't want to
that's not what you're supposed to do as
a doctor
yeah all right um okay our next guest i
believe we have him on the line
uh token owen is a huge fan here he was
like please please we have to have a
monitor
i'm not i'm not a sports guy but i know
who this this is
yeah i know i don't know a whole lot
about sports but i know about him
because of twitter and the culture we'll
talk about sports
i know he's not here to talk about
sports i'm just saying his background
fox sports espn um he played division
one uh
football which is intimidating and i'm
glad he's on skype
um and uh he recently got suspended from
twitter for
uh criticizing the black lives matter
founder oh this one patrice khan
trees there's so many founders it's hard
to keep uh she bought that
mansion yeah she bought the 1.4 million
dollar mansion
but i think he's back on right now um on
on twitter jason uh jason whitlock are
you there sir
i am here can you hear me i can hear you
and look at that so wonderful i'm glad
to have you on i'm sorry that we ran
late
when we start talking about uh you know
puberty blockers for children i get a
little i get a little riled up
i don't blame you uh i i don't get it as
a former athlete
uh i and i don't get why women aren't
more outraged
about this and just parents and mothers
uh you know it's an unfair competition
i don't know how many kids are we even
talking about too as it relates to
do do we how many kids are transgender
or want to change sex
well now they're it used to be 0.6 and
now there's it's over 2
in schools so it skyrocketed there were
actually more transgen
kids who identified as transgender than
have ever identified as lesbian and so
that brings in the nature
nurture argument um where it's like why
would there be this
skyrocketing number of them and uh we
don't have a lot of them competing in
women's sports
now in the past but it looks like you
know every
women's record probably be gone pretty
soon
i agree with the solution of just a
transgender league
yeah and they can compete amongst
themselves and a steroid league because
if you have someone you know who's
transgender on testosterone
then anyone there should be able to take
whatever they want and just let the
games begin
i mean you let me ask you this you
played obviously division one ball and
that's
a contact sport we just showed some uh
clips of a
male identifying as woman playing
handball and just face bombing kids
when you were playing football there
were some people i'm sure there were
open secrets who had
used performance-enhancing drugs right
yes
and you could say could you sense that
difference i know when i've just done
even local grappling tournaments and
there's someone who you've been up
against
and then six months later you this is
not the same person it was drastic
it was i had a weird take on that
because
i certainly i played in the 80s i'm old
but because i had a i was strong
and the strongest guy on our team yeah
uh
and so i really didn't care what the
other guys did
because it was a non-issue for me
strength was not something i struggled
with
uh you know eating was something i
struggled with but not strength
and but it was funny
the coaches actually favored
the steroid users over someone like me
i i was a bit of a locker room lawyer
and i can remember
very good friend of mine uh i would
the bench press was the big deal and you
know whoever convinced the most was a
big deal
your picture was up in the locker room
in a prominent place
and the coaches hated me so much that
they
let someone else retest months later
after he did a steroid cycle
and he broke my record and they put his
picture up immediately
i didn't care that guy was a friend of
mine you know we played different
positions but
wow uh yeah there's well you know gerald
here who
he played football at notre dame and
he's so glib he didn't think that people
took steroids so
wait they do joke here they do that they
take steroids yeah
he knew a guy he was like this guy was
275 with six percent body fat
ripped and uh no steroids i'm like are
you are you out of your mind
he's an innocent he's innocent he didn't
do steroids though no he didn't do
steroids
this doesn't look like his freakish guys
he squatted like 500 something his first
time accidentally so sorry we got off on
uh
off the beaten path now jason are you
back on twitter i know you were
suspended are you allowed back now
yeah they suspended me on friday and
then they let me back in on
tuesday uh they said that i reached out
to them
i did not reach out to them i just think
they got beaten up so bad
by people raising the question like why
the hell did you do this to this guy
uh that they folded and sent me an
apology and for people who don't know
the tweet and question
uh that resulted in it from what we know
is you tweeted that the black lives
matter founder bought a 1.4 million
dollar home in topanga which has a black
population of 1.4 percent
and then you add a little sting to it
saying she's with her people
um which i appreciate and that got you
into trouble i mean
look this is something you've spoken out
quite a bit with black lives matter and
i know that you've
you've been in media for a long time um
what is your how most people reacted to
you in this industry
oh people in the sports media lane and
just in the media in general
are scared to death of black lives
matter they're scared to death of
any type of twitter twitter lynch mob
coming after them and criticizing him
you don't want to be on the wrong side
of this argument because they'll paint
you as either racist
or a sellout to black people and so
everybody avoids the truth
everybody knows the black lives matter
movement
is not about black men it's not about
uh george floyd
raychart brooks jacob blake it's an
lgbtq agenda
right black lives matter the whole black
men thing is just a smoke screen
it was founded by three lgbt
women i know it's hard for me to
remember the acronyms too
so yeah well i call them the alphabet
mafia yes
the alphabet mafia is in control of
social media and twitter
uh jack dorsey has stated i think in the
interview with joe rogan he
stated twitter's there to amplify
certain voices
right and the alphabet mafia is the
voice that they have amplified
and you know i've just been very
critical because it's all been a hustle
it's all been about money it's all been
about
agendas outside police brutality yeah
and it's all been a distortion of the
truth because police brutality and
and i say this having lost a close
relative a cousin that i helped raise
was killed by police in 2012
in indianapolis i actually understand
the injustice of police brutality
but it's greatly overblown in america
that there's 50 million 100 million
engagements police have
with our citizens and a very tiny
percentage of them spin out of control
and lead to someone die you know people
often talk about like white privilege
and stuff like that and
and the issue here is obviously
identifying people um exclusively by the
race is a problem
but i will say something here uh as a
white person uh i do feel a privilege
and i talked with
someone about this that changed my mind
where i
have not um as a white man no one says
you have to fit into this specific box
in other words
when i'm a kid i can listen to metal i
can listen to hip-hop i can listen to
country and no one says you're not white
enough you know whereas i had a black
friend who was an iron maiden fan
and his friends said like man you're not
black and i go oh that's not something i
really experience
and you get that in the media too um
where it's
you don't have the right opinions as
black and what's interesting is
the overwhelming majority of black
americans want at least as much
or more police presence than they
currently have in their communities
and we've been talking about this and i
go to a church that's mixed
i feel and i know a lot of the black
people there even though they're
christians they vote democrat but i feel
a lot more comfortable around black
democrats we have more in common than
the white democrats right now it's
almost like black democrats if you look
at the actual
represe in america as opposed to who's
speaking in the media
they're the moderate wing of the
democratic party your views that you're
talking about right now
are far more representative
statistically in poll after poll
of the average black american than the
talking head on cnn
why do they why is it white people on
twitter removing you for having the
wrong black opinion
because stephen and this is just
the truth and i'm sorry anybody gets
offended about
the white liberal is the actual
out of the closet bigot the white
liberal
is the direct descendant mentally
and world point of view as it relates to
race
the director senate of slave owners and
bigots they believe that
black is a special category of human
beings
that restricts your freedom
right and that's what they believed in
1600s that's what these white liberals
believe now
and that's why they want to capitalize
the be in black because we're a special
category of human beings
and so we want to designate them over
here and they can only think one way
and just as as you said we're the only
people
that have no political freedom
uh because if we and again i'm a
non-voter and i
i tend to abhor politics and politicians
on both sides
i have in recent years just like
discover like man this white liberal
thing
this is some pure racism i guess that
pure racism on the other side
uh but but as black people again if you
think any conservative thought if you
stay true to what you were taught
in the church oh my god you've sold
black people out
and i just refused to do that i i
i would rather have group think and
social media think i'm a sell out
of my skin color than to think i'm a
sellout of jesus christ
and my christian beliefs i'm going to
stand on careful
jesus christ and i are getting into
western civilization and
patriarchy we have to be careful we need
a female deity i'm not a patriarch
yeah you are that's also one thing too i
will say
it's it's this unholy alliance because
when you look at like liberals and they
talk about the patriarchy i go
do you understand that in the black
community like gender roles are
way more clearly defined like they don't
have a problem with this idea of
masculinity either they just
they just want black people's votes yeah
you got to use the word word because
they're blurring those lines
and they've been very effective this
little mind control thing they do
like if you you know the number one
thing you can do as a black person
is hate donald trump that's how you
prove that you're black
and we gotta snap out of that yeah the
number one thing you can do as a black
person is be responsible for yourself
and be responsible for whatever you
create
on this planet and that that's how
but but they just you know you gotta
hate donald trump you gotta think all
white people and republicans are
your enemy and none of it is about the
man in the mirror it's always about
someone outside who's in control of your
life and it just it drives me crazy
i sit and laugh and i'm listening to you
talk about the church you go to and
be in mixed race and it confirms the
thought that i had about you just
following you and your show and the
controversy from afar
the reason why you're so daring is
because
in your actual life you don't live a
racist life
and so it makes you more fearless in
your public
job on this show whereas the people that
are doing all the social mimick
gimmicks and virtue signaling if you go
examine their real life
it's it's not as diverse it's not as
inclusive
now as you're no not at all here's the
thing the left believes that uh race
identifies
every facet of human being and needs to
be the defining factor
uh but is off limits for jokes and i'm
exact opposite like race doesn't mean
all that much
but it's fun for for jokes that's what
we have about a half asian lawyer we
have
i mean we have a pretty diverse group of
people here um
matter of fact probably the most racist
person here is a colombian but it's only
against argentinians
he hates them he hates argentinians the
tribalism from south americans don't get
him started on argentinians
yeah it's uh to me we just didn't change
my mind uh that'll be coming out uh
monday or tuesday on oppo to me opposing
voter id is racist
and this is something people what do you
mean i said look i have not heard an
argument in opposition to voter id
because they have all said voter id is
racist it disenfranchises minorities
those are the that's
the premise and i said and i was
speaking with a black student i said
i've never heard an argument
that strikes me as anything other than
deeply racist he said what do you mean i
said
the idea that black people can't get an
id he said well a lot of them don't have
ideas i said well statistically that's
not true it's
anywhere from 86 to 90 of the population
but why do you think they can't get an
id
so because some of them don't live near
a dmv i said well
statistically they live in urban areas
statistically if you're gonna talk about
disenfranchising voters it would be the
white rural farmer
because they might have to drive an hour
and a half i said so you don't think
black people can they live near
can they use a bus can they drive a lot
of black people don't drive i said okay
can they fill it out online
a lot of black people don't know how to
use the internet i see this is what i'm
saying that sounds kind of racist
no it's not kinda it's rape
right it's racist
one of the things conservative people
say is they call it soft bigotry
and i'm totally against you got to
eliminate the word
soft it's just big the the bigotry of
low expectations it's not the bigotry of
or it's not the soft bigotry of low
expectations
it is the bigotry of low expectations
and they hit us with that all the time
and the number one reason why i'm
against that
is because i've succeeded
in corporate america despite i probably
graduated high school with a 2.8 grade
point average
i was kind of a class clown in college
i was drunk high playing football
uh you're basically a method man who was
hitting people on the field
yeah yeah didn't take school basically
graduated with a 2.3
i'm not special i moved into the
corporate world
and mostly i just show up and i do what
i'm asked to do
and then you know i attended the writing
stuff i do it now at a high level but
again it's not
i'm not special and so all you have to
do is try
and we're the left is trying to convince
but
don't try you have no chance this whole
world is against you
you have no shot ignore jason whitlock's
300 pound ass who got a national
television show
on fox sports and got to do espn
and got to earn a [ __ ] ton of money
ignore him
you know i don't fit the profile of a tv
star
but i was paid like one so you can't
tell me
that we can't accomplish these things
and that you know america is sober and
and uh stephen in 1984 my senior year in
high school me and my dad
were dirt poor we lived in a one bedroom
400 square foot apartment
in the ghetto so nobody can
convince me and trust 2.8 grade point
average i was a pretty good football
player
but no one can convince me
that there's these uh barriers that we
can't overcome as poor black people
if we just try and i'm so irate with the
people
so don't even try you have no shock
you know don't give it away you can't do
anything without us
or the government though i will try and
convince you because i think you may
still be eligible to play
women's college football and that could
be fun gerald here who played at notre
dame he has a question for you and then
we're going to go to to mug club so
youtube doesn't ban us but what's your
question there gerald
jason so you said something earlier that
the media is basically especially the
sports media is kind of bowing
at the altar of blm right you said
they're just afraid of them
right it you have stepped out and
charles barkley got in a lot of hot
water recently for kind of stuff
knucklehead and just saying everybody
was probably pretty decent at the core i
didn't think that was controversial
terrible are there are there other
people in this in this environment in
the media network in the sports media
um black men that would come to you and
say that they agreed behind the scenes
but just
wouldn't have the ability or maybe the
courage to go and say it on air or
something like that are there more
people out there that can say because
honestly
steven and i can say this all we want
but having another white guy say it
doesn't quite carry the same amount of
weight i'm not saying it doesn't matter
i'm just
a clear guy like you well
i think that it's tough to be quite
honest with you because
if you get social media backlash
the executives the white executives they
get scared
oh my god you know i don't i don't want
my employees seen as being
anti-black or sellouts or racist
and so so many executives are controlled
by social media
that i don't blame a lot of black media
people
for living in fear of social media and
yes i think
many of them agree with a lot of things
that i say
uh they don't feel like they're free to
save them without
facing severe repercussions
uh and so they don't you gotta remember
i'm single with no kids
and so i get to be a bit more fearless
than
some 45 year old guy that's got a wife
and two kids and
he gets on the wrong side of twitter
loses his job
his wife's pretty angry with him he
probably never gets laid again
you're describing my life sweetheart uh
hey well thanks for taking that risk for
all of them yeah
you're in a position to do it you did it
you could have just stepped you know you
could have just stead pat and not done
it so thank you
it's a little less of a risk when you're
a 300 pound black man
you know they'll only tweet at you it's
the geraldo rivera dan bongino you son
of a [ __ ]
you punk it's like oh man i know where
you live oh no
i thought you were i don't know i'm old
yeah i'm old
i'm blind no i compete in women's
divisions
all right hey uh jason we're going to go
to uh mug club here uh but where's the
while we're still on youtube where's the
best place for people to support you
well uh at whitlock jason on twitter for
right now and
very soon i'm gonna announce what i'm
gonna be doing next
uh and i'll just have to ask people to
stay tuned for that okay all right and
we're gonna stand in line with jason
whitlock here so
we go to mug club where he can say what
he really thinks well i guess
he wants to stomp some crackers uh
youtube thank you so much piss off